Justin Timberlake heading back to the
Superbowl here's what we know
Plus Khloe Kardashian is pregnant
they're multiplying I was literally just
talking about Kylie yesterday and I told
you something else is up and boom Khloe
is also expecting we're on that in just
a few but first some other big news
today
it looks like Justin Timberlake is going
to perform at Super Bowl 52 and some
where Janet Jackson is thinking what it
has been 13 years since his
controversial halftime performance with
Janet you know the one with the now
infamous wardrobe malfunction and now a
source tells et that Justin is close to
finalizing a deal to headline halftime
for next year's Superbowl although he
hasn't signed anything yet we're told an
agreement has been made now this will
actually be JT's third trip back to
football's biggest stage and while the
NFL is being tight-lipped telling et we
are not going to speculate on particular
artists our source says quote this is
who they wanted for a long time he's the
guy that same source tells us that
Justin and his team have not started
conceptualizing the performance just yet
but if you have any piercings Justin may
suggest you keep them to yourself well
one thing's for sure Justin got a big
thumbs up from his pal former Dallas
Cowboys quarterback Tony Romo the NFL
analyst is team JT I love Justin I think
he's a great guy
I think he's talented
we play golf sometimes somedays I got to
give them tips other days he's giving me
a tip so I think if they got Justin that
would be a home run I think he's one of
the rare guys that everyone thinks is
great he's super talented super talented
but what do you guys think are we here
for Justin Timberlake for Super Bowl 52
or not and if he is the guy what song
should he perform I want to hear and let
us know well listen if there was a Super
Bowl for babies the Kardashians would
win that hands down because oh my god
Khloe Kardashian is pregnant too I can't
keep up I'm gonna try source close to
Chloe tells et she is expecting her
first child early next year with
Cleveland Cavaliers boyfriend of over a
year Tristan Thompson and in case you
lost count that means there are three
kardashian-jenner babies coming 20
year-old kylie is having a baby girl
with Travis Scott and Kim and Kanye are
expecting their third child also a girl
via a surrogate now the family has still
not said anything publicly about all of
this though shortly after news broke
Khloe was pregnant
Tristan seemingly responded by tweeting
these cryptic eye emojis but if history
is to be repeated we predict all three
sisters will confirm the news themselves
at the end of Sunday's season 14
premiere after all that's what they did
for season 9 with Courtney's pregnancy
and season 10 with Kim I mean well I
don't watch the show oh cool okay let's
get into some pop stars supporting other
pop stars Beyonce sent a care package to
Lady Gaga who was forced to cancel the
European leg of her world tour due to
her chronic pain be sent Gaga flowers
and a comfy Ivy Park sweatshirt which
Mother Monster said is keeping her warm
outside in her hammock on a bad pain
date and by the way guys I was looking
up that picture of the flowers and
zooming in on Beyonce's note to her and
I believe it says thinking about you and
sending you so much love praying for a
quick recovery isn't that nice gotta
love Beyonce well listen the ladies are
getting information because Taylor Swift
also sent flowers to cardi B after the
rapper's bowed AK yellow knock look what
you made me do off the top of the
Billboard Hot 100 chart cardi returned
the love telling Taylor
she freakin loves her music and the
thing is I used to be Malik Gayle I have
to be Taylor Swift I like I like that
damn song but you make me to look but
you make me too and there's just I can't
believe that is like okay yeah hey
number one but it's like it's like
history can I just say how much I love
cardi B she's so crazy all right yeah
that's right cardi is the first female
solo rapper to top the Billboard Hot 100
since Lauryn Hill's due up but not
everyone is congratulating cardi on her
success and since the Leda tweets
Azealia Banks called cardi the poor
man's Nicki as in Nicki Minaj and said
quote she's only black when black wanna
include themselves in a success story
well cardi caught wind of the disk and
served us with this Gloria's clap back
it's Azalea dancing to her song in the
club writing one of the reasons Bo doc
yellow went number one because even the
haters love it and that right there that
kind of clap back nourishes my soul and
I don't know how many times as a Lea has
to revamp her career into the ground
there is room for everybody success
people are you guys clearly I'm hyped on
that that's it for us today thank you so
much for watching and be sure to
subscribe to e t--'s youtube channel so
you don't miss another episode under
daily Denny and until tomorrow I'm gonna
be bouncing to broad idea I'm on the
cardi B train I gotta say
[Music]